I thought Black Friday was a TGIF owned
by Magic Johnson it's the busiest
shopping day of the season for anyone to
dumb to use Amazon this may look like an
audition for The Biggest Loser but we're
actually in Buffalo which is the perfect
name for a frozen city full of chubby
people but they after Thanksgiving odds
are at least half of them have the
cranberry squirts hopefully they
trampled that Alex from Target kid if
you only look kinda hot from one angle
you don't deserve to be famous this is
why I shop at Walmart so when things get
hairy
I can buy gun those are the panicked
shrieks of a man who knows he's about to
miss out on all the 4xl Maronna
sweatshirts
maybe if we raise the minimum wage a few
these fat bucks could afford to waddle
over to Nordstrom and I pull it together
mister stop being a and go
purchase your family's love no man
should ever want to go to a mall this
badly
[Applause]
[Music]
try pushing
he knows there's no boss of them all
right someone's addicted to Wetzel's
pretzels
[Applause]
because those are our hours finally
somebody's coming to help my fans don't
just look to me for jokes that's why I'm
gonna tell you my picks for the best
presents to give your loved ones this
holiday season first up is the hottest
toy of the year I'm sure your child has
already asked for it it's cornhole Me
Elmo
yeah with a real working anus I would
have pictured it more pink at last an
Elmo kids can consider the other way
around
next it's never too early to teach your
baby about the Second Amendment
that's why fisher-price and Smith &
Wesson collaborated to create my first
handgun
it's colorful there's no sharp edges and
it fires genuine 22 caliber bullets oh
you can have this gun when you pry it
from his warm-napping hands
now because I know you all want me to
watch you shower my next gift suggestion
is a big shower curtain with my face on
it and the best part it comes with a rod
that is bent in the opposite direction
so it's guaranteed to uncomfortably
cling to your body throughout the entire
cleansing process